- How did you become comfortable
with putting yourself out there again?
- Oh my God.
- Is this hard?
- I mean that, back to therapy.
- yeah
- I mean,
I think a lot of it was really
learning how to be able to
take the things that you generally hear
on a daily basis you know,
- yeah
- of course there's so much.
There's so much feedback that
you're getting on a constant
basis and it's hard to like shut it off
or not listen to people.
But what I've done now is
I've really learned that
like I genuinely do, like
I'm a child of the internet.
I grew up on message boards.
And, and so I don't,
it's so sad,
but I don't feel complete
without having those
people along with me for the journey of,
of everything that I go through you know.
whether it's so difficult to
live in front of the public
and, and, and have these things
happen in front of everybody.
I do feel like they're along for the ride.
And so for people to see
live time my growth and and
and the things that I go through
and how I deal with them.
And I like them along for all that.
And so when that's missing from my life,
when I, when social is, is gone,
I don't have that interaction with people.
I feel like a bit incomplete.
And when I'm cooking or something,
when I have this natural urge,
I'm like, I got to film this.
I got it. Like, well, .
- Well that makes sense
no. cause that's like what
You do in the public eye too.
And that's what peer so
good at it. And like people,
that's something that's like interact
- Interact balance is not it's,
it's being able to have
that balance of like, okay,
it's okay not to share
this with the entire world.
- yeah
- And versus, you know,
and sometimes it looks like
we do share everything.
I'm sure it looks like I
share absolutely everything,
but now
- yeah
- it still is a, you know,
a moment of like being able
to, where people see what
they get to see, and that's fine.
- yeah